♪ ♪ ♪
- Seattle, sur la côte ouest
américaine. Avec son boom
économique et démographique,
c'est la ville américaine
qui grossit le plus vite.
Devant les problèmes de
congestion de plus en plus
évidents, on a donc décidé
de changer les choses.
Un matin de semaine comme
un autre pour Nicolas Duchatel.
Le Québécois, qui habite
la région de Seattle depuis
15 ans, vit en banlieue,
à 35 km du centre-ville,
où il travaille.
Jadis, il aurait pris
sa voiture pour s'y rendre.
Mais aujourd'hui, il l'utilise
seulement pour aller au
stationnement incitatif.
NICOLAS DUSCHATEL
- L'avantage, c'est d'aller
à l'autre "park & ride",
le Kingsville "park & ride",
plus au sud, où il y a
trois autobus, mais comme
je dis, il est rempli
à 7 h 30, 7 h 45.
- Il peut choisir entre
quatre stationnements gratuits
dans un rayon de 3 km
autour de chez lui.
Une fois sur place, son autobus
à destination du centre-ville
passe aux 15 minutes.
Depuis cinq ans,
le transport en commun
s'améliore sans cesse à Seattle.
- Par exemple, ce "park & ride"
ici a été élargi. Ils font
des programmes incitatifs pour
essayer de faire du covoiturage
vert, le "park & ride".
Les autobus ont été un peu...
allongé, l'horaire.
- L'autobus de Nicolas
prendra une vingtaine
de minutes seulement
pour arriver au centre-ville.
Merci aux voies réservées;
il y en a 410 km dans
le comté de Seattle,
comparativement à 258 km
pour toute l'île de Montréal.
Christina O'Clair
était heureuse de nous
montrer un nouveau tronçon
inauguré le 22 février.
À Seattle, ces voies réservées
peintes en rouge sont partout.
"Avec la Ville, on a déterminé
que 50 % des voies devraient
être réservées aux autobus parce
qu'environ la moitié des gens
utilisent l'autobus, dit-elle.
Nos décisions se prennent en
fonction du nombre d'usagers,
pas du nombre de véhicules."
C'est ici, sur la 3e Avenue,
au centre-ville de Seattle,
qu'on réalise à quel point
la région a misé sur
le transport en commun
au cours des dernières années.
La 3e Avenue est devenue
le plus important corridor
d'autobus aux États-Unis.
De 6 h le matin à 7 h le soir,
l'avenue est maintenant
interdite aux voitures.
45 lignes de bus passent
donc ici et elles transportent
180 000 usagers chaque jour.
♪ ♪ ♪
"Le transport en commun
n'est pas le deuxième choix,
c'est le premier et c'est le cas
parce que notre réseau est
rapide, fiable et sécuritaire",
ajoute Christina O'Clair.
Pour ce faire, il y a cinq ans,
la Ville a multiplié ses mesures
de financement dédiées
au transport collectif.
"Nous demandons maintenant
60 $ de frais d'immatriculation
pour chaque véhicule
et la taxe de vente
a été augmentée de 0,1 %",
explique le responsable
du département des transports.
Avec cet argent, 8000 nouveaux
trajets d'autobus ont été
ajoutés sur le réseau.
(ding! ding! ding!)
Il y a aussi le train léger,
inauguré en 2009 et qui sert
aussi de métro. Il est en pleine
expansion; un peu partout en
banlieue, on voit les travaux
de son prolongement.
D'ici 2024, 60 km seront
ajoutés à son réseau.
"Dans le comté aujourd'hui,
nous dépensons plus pour
le transport en commun que
pour les routes, ajoute-t-il.
En fait, la région de Seattle
est celle qui y investirait
le plus depuis 2008
aux États-Unis. Deux plans
de développement totalisant
72 milliards de dollars ont
d'ailleurs été approuvés par
référendum, en 2008 et 2016.
Nicolas est un de ceux
qui ont voté pour.
- C'est de réaliser que
la mobilité dans la ville
est la question la plus
importante pour les gens.
- Les citoyens ont même voté
pour une autre taxe régionale
plus corsée dédiée au transport.
Et encore là, ce sont
les automobilistes qui paient.
- Grosso modo, c'est 1 %
de la valeur de la voiture,
donc si c'est une auto
qui vaut 10 000 $, bien,
c'est peut-être 100 $ de taxes.
- Chaque année?
- Chaque année.
- Pour sa BMW,
il a payé 450 $ en 2018.
"La circulation
est devenue circulation
est devenue terrible,
alors les gens se sont dit :
'Ouvrons nos portefeuilles
et votons pour améliorer
le transport en commun'",
explique Gene Balk,
chroniqueur au "Seattle Times".
Aujourd'hui, cette taxe
sur les voitures est toutefois
contestée devant les tribunaux
parce que les résidents
des banlieues éloignées
ne veulent plus la payer.
- Je pense qu'on réalise
pas que sans avoir
ces investissements,
ça va être encore...
incroyablement plus pire.
- Pire en raison de l'expansion
de Seattle, où la circulation
y est souvent très lourde.
Mais alors qu'à Montréal et
qu'un peu partout en Amérique
du Nord, la place de l'auto
continue de croître...
... à Seattle, précise
Gene Balk, le pourcentage
de ménages qui possèdent
une voiture a diminué
de 3 % de 2010 à 2018.
L'évolution du transport en
commun y serait pour beaucoup.
"Build it, and they will come",
peut-on dire ici.